- Welcome everyone to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning,
Today we're a bit of an unusual location,
here we are at the Eat and Style.
We're invited by a friend of mine
who has a food startup
that we are going to visit,
it's a food fair, so we
are very excited for that.
But the topic of today
is going to be what is
called the Great Resignation,
this trend of especially young people
preferring now to work at home,
working very flexibly instead
of working in an office
needing to come into the
office on a regular basis.
I'm going to weigh into that,
give my opinion on that,
and especially I will talk about
whether I believe it is a good idea
for people fresh out of university
in the first years of their career
to work in a job that is fully remote,
to work somewhere where
they're not in direct contact
with colleagues, but just
at home working from home,
whether this is a great idea or not.
And as a small hint, I don't
think that it's a great idea.
I know that this is a
little bit controversial,
but we're going to dive
into this in a moment
so stick in here with me.
I got the idea for this video this morning
right in my LinkedIn feed
at this post from McKinsey
saying "Employees are
quitting in record numbers,
many without another role lined up.
It's up to leaders to
respond to these trends
and re-engage the workforce
so organizations can
retain their best talent."
And this trend, this phenomena
that is described here
is called the Great Resignation.
It is widely described
and apparently it's also backed up by data
that since earlier this
year a lot of people
apparently much more than normal
are resigning from their job,
and this is often linked
to the development
during the health situation
that was going on since last year
and the thought process that
this triggered for many people.
Apparently this is especially triggered
by millennials and Gen Z people
that are not really satisfied
anymore with their job.
And I couldn't confirm that, when talking
to people, friends, colleagues,
who tell me that they
don't wanna work anymore
in the same way that they used to work,
maybe before the situation since 2019.
A big trend seems to be that
people do not want to work
from an office anymore,
that people want to work
remote, want to work from home
and this full-time.
And of course, I do see
many advantages to that.
Of course, especially
if you have a family,
and another big plus that I see
is that often this gives you
a little bit more flexibility
to on the side work on some
other project of yours,
some other passions that
you really want to follow.
So for this let's hear it
from Johannes from SPICEWISE,
he's a Rocket Scientist
working a full-time job,
and he started his passion project
during this time in the pandemic.
So Johannes from SPICEWISE was kind enough
to invite us here today
to the Eat in Style,
lots of amazing food, we
already also tried out yours,
pretty amazing stuff.
So, the topic we already talked about it,
the Great Resignation.
That's pretty amazing because I think
you did not resign from your full-time job
with your project,
but it also had something to
do with the health situation,
is that correct?
- Yes, so thank you very much
for your time and visiting us
at our SPICEWISE booth.
Yes, you're right, we
used the current situation
together with my kindergarten friends
to develop a natural supplement,
and we did it, yeah part time.
So, we all three, we stayed
in our full-time jobs,
yeah, tried to perform very good,
but also used for example the
extra time during lockdown
where you cannot go out to
the cinema or whatsoever
to develop a product or in this case,
particular case three products.
Yeah, and fulfill our childhood dream
to, yeah, develop and found the company,
and yeah, today you are here
at our booth of SPICEWISE
and this is the result.
- That's pretty amazing,
and this, what I
understand this whole move
we know of the Great
Resignation what it's all about,
people in a full-time job asking
themselves, what can we do?
What is really our passion?
What are some projects we want to pursue?
And is it correct that
you did this fully remote?
So really also an example of working
completely from home?
- Yes.
- How did this team of
yours work together?
- So the team is spread through Germany,
so we have someone Wurzburg,
someone in Stuttgart,
and me in Munich.
And during the lockdown we
was not able to come together
to work in a kind of a
workshop or whatsoever.
Also our suppliers needed
to work fully remote.
So, actually it was a very great workflow
because we start I think
to invest more time
in during August/September 2020.
From my point of view,
it was very, very good
and a great flow, yeah.
- Thanks, that awesome.
If you are also interested
in this SPICEWISE products
I will link a link in
the video description
to their products, so check it out,
trust it is really amazing.
Thank you Johannes, much appreciated.
- Thank you very much, good bye.
- This for sure is quite
an inspirational story,
and of course this begs the question,
that if you are young professional,
someone fresh out of university,
should you choose your first job
to be a job that is fully remote,
that gives you all this flexibility?
And apparently this is something
that many young graduates
currently are contemplating a lot,
and that also led to
this Great Resignation,
this trend that we talked
about in the beginning.
And frankly while I understand
that it's already popular
and while I do see the advantages,
I think it is not a good idea.
This is my humble
opinion on this question.
And let me share three reasons with you
why I believe that
especially as a new joiner,
as a young professional,
you should rather look for a job
that is a bit more in this way,
that allows you to work from the office
and get this experience this way.
The first point is that I hold
that a significant part of the learnings
that you get from a job
in the first years of your
career is by observation,
by sitting in the office and
maybe over hearing a phone call
that maybe a colleague has,
who's sitting next to you,
and this colleague maybe
just has a client call,
a call with the client and
whole call is a bit difficult,
doesn't go the way the person planned,
and you're just observing
what this person is doing
in order to handle the
situation in the right way.
On the same way observing how
some of the senior leaders
who you just meet in the office,
handle certain situations,
interact and engage with
the other colleagues,
with clients, with suppliers.
Observations that are not crucial,
that are not directly linked
to your day-to-day activities
are an extremely rich source of learning
that you will just really
not be able to tap into
by just sitting in front
of your desk at home,
joining some occasional video conferences,
you will miss this for sure.
The second point is on visibility.
Your visibility will for sure suffer
if the only way other colleagues see you
is if they join a video conference
where you are part of as well.
And if you're not really familiar
with this concept of visibility,
I do hope that it is one of
the most important concepts
to understand especially in
the first years of your career
to succeed, I will link
another video above here
where I talked about this
in details, so check it out.
But for sure if you're sitting at home,
you're missing the opportunity
of meeting other people
in the office, having an
informal coffee with them,
picking up things that are going on
where you can be a part of,
where you can increase your visibility,
this will not benefit your
long-term career progression
in an organization.
The third point is about opportunity.
I know many companies are in
a bit of a weird situation
where part of the workforce
is in the office on a regular basis,
while the other part of the workforce
is mainly working from home.
Also because in many
organizations, to some extent
is up to the discretion of
the individual employees
whether they wanna come
to the office or not.
And I would argue that
in these organizations,
the people who are not
regularly in the office
have some significant disadvantages.
Now try to put yourself into the shoes
of a team leader or the
leader in this organization,
the person sitting in the office
and has now a couple of things
to discuss with other people
or an idea the person now wants
to work with with another person.
What is the person that this leader
will be most likely to reach out to?
And I would argue that
most likely this person
will reach out to a colleague
who is sitting in the office,
next to him or her,
to whom this colleague
can directly reach out
to discuss a certain
thing with that person,
and then often this leads to
some follow-up activities,
maybe a whole new project
that this person can now lead
because he was present, he
was there, he was available
to discuss these things with this leader.
So while I fully acknowledge
that working from home,
working in a remote position
has some significant advantages,
I don't think it's the
best move you can do
if you really want to grow as a person
and as a professional.
I trust that not everyone
will have my opinion on this
and this is of course completely okay.
So let me know, what is your opinion?
Feel free to leave a comment
below in the comment section,
would love to hear from you as well.
As always if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
and also subscribe to the channel.
I'm also active on other platforms
such as Instagram,
LinkedIn, Twitch, or TikTok.
And of course a big, big thanks
to all the members Firm Learning,
thanks for your contribution,
my name is Heinrich
I release a new video
every single Saturday,
so see you again next week.
Until then, all the
best to you and bye-bye.